الطباعه ثلاثيه الابعاد اصبحت متعدده
لاستخدامات في حياتنا بشكل لا يصدق سواء
ببلاستيك او اسمنت وحتى الخلايا الحيوانيه
هذه المره ستغزو الفضاء لاول مره بصاروخ
سيقلع من ولايه فلوريدا الامريكيه
وسيساهم نجاح اطلاق صاروخ
في احداث الثوره في صناعه مركبات الفضاء
واثبات قدرته على مقاومه ضغط الاقلاع
وستبث شركه ريلات عمليه الاطلاق التي تعمل
ان تكون ناجحه بعد تاجيلها وذلك عبر
قناتها في موقع يوتيوب
اذا ما نجحت تجربه صاروخ سيكون اول صاروخ
مصنوع بتقنيه الطباعه ثلاثيه الابعاد يصل
الى المدار وصنع 85% من كتله الصاروخ
باتباع ثلاثيه الابعاد وتطلع الشركه الى
ان ترفع هذه النسبه الى 95%
الفوائد كثيره وعلى راسها تقليل تكاليف
وتبسط عمليه التصنيع وتقول الشركه ان عدد
الاجزاء اقل ب 100 مره عن تلك التي لا
تتطلبها بناء صاروخ تقليدي كما تشدد على
سرعه هذه الطريقه موضحه ان عمليه الانتاج
تستغرق 60 يوما فقط من المواد الخام الى
المنتج النهائي ويبلغ ارتفاع الصاروخ
33.5 مترا وقطره اقل بقليل من مترين وتضم
طبقته الاولى تسعه محركات انتجت بطباعه
ثلاثيه الابعاد ايضا وطبقته الثانيه محركا
واحدا فقط
[موسيقى]
من الكويت ينضم الينا استاذ مساعد بكليه
الدراسات التكنولوجيه سابقا للدكتور محمد
قاسم دكتور يسعد صباحك استعداد لاطلاق
صاروخ او صاروخ مصنوع بتقنيه طباعه ثلاثيه
الابعاد نتحدث اكثر عن هذه التقنيه وصلت
الى الفضاء ما الذي ستضيفه
طبعا اهلا وسهلا فيكم وصباح الخير بكل
تاكيد هذه التقنيه
جديده ولم تستخدم سابقا في صناعه الصواريخ
فلان عندنا لاول مره صناعه الصواريخ عن
طريق بعد ثلاثيه الابعاد
الشيء الاساسي اللي فيها طبعا هناك شيء
جانبيه مهمين لهذا الموضوع الجانب الاول
ان الطباعه ستوفر على الشركه امكانيه
تفضل سامعين ومركزين دكتور
اع هذه راح
توفر عده شركات لاخذ قطع غيار مختلفه كلها
تطبع في شركه واحده فهذا اللي حدث حاليا
مع الشركه هذا رقم واحد رقم اثنين انا كنت
اكلم طب ما هو رقم واحد بس نوقف عنده يعني
اذا انت بتقول بسهل عليها ومش مضطره تجيب
اجزاء من كذا شركه طيب ما هو مرات كل شركه
تتميز بهذه التقنيه المعينه من اجل الوصول
الى الشكل النهائي للصاروخ الفضائي اليوم
هل هذا يعني بان تقنيه ثلاثيه الابعاد
لتوظيف صاروخ فضائي يعني بذات الامكانيات
وذات المواصفات الى الفضاء
السؤال جدا ممتاز وهذا ينقلني للنقطه
الثانيه اللي تبين اهميه الطباعه الثقافه
انا كنت اكلم لينكايزر صحه صاحب شركه
هايبرغان اللي هو يستخدم طباعه ثلاثيه
الابعاد وكذلك الذكاء الاصطناعي لبناء
محركات صواريخ لا يستطيع حتى الانسان انه
يصنعها من خلال القوانين الرياضيه فما
يحدث الان ان هم يستخدمون شركه تستخدم
الذكاء الاصطناعي لبناء الصواريخ بطريقه
غير تقليديه فتاه
فليس فقط توفير قطع غيار جاهزه من خلال
الطباع انما حتى الافكار الجديده اللي
توضع في الصواريخ لم تكن موجوده في السابق
لان الذكاء الاصطناعي معنا اليوم طبعا
نتحدث عن معايير هكذا صواريخ بطبيعه
ثلاثيه الابعاد يعني من حيث قدرتها على
مقاومه الضغط الجماعه البيانات الفضاء
ايضا من حيث ان ها اقل تكلفه واكثر سرعه
في التصنيع
بالضبط يعني حاليا التكاليف اقل وكذلك
الماده المستخدمه فيها اسهل ولا تكلف ايام
كثيره حتى تصل الى الطبع النهائي يعني
اليوم هم قادرين خلال 60 يوم فقط انه
يصنعون المحرك للصاروخ فهذا الشيء جدا
اساسي للموضوع وما كان متوفر طيب دكتور
محمد هل يمكن الحديث اليوم عن الوقود
المستعمل في هذه العمليه هو وقود مناسب
ملائم للمناخ وقود المستقبل
طبعا هو ليس من حيث المناخ انما الوقود
المستخدم اللي هو وقود الغاز الطبيعي ولكن
مسيل وكذلك الاكسجين الهدف الاساسي
منه هو هدف الاساسي الصاروخ الى المريخ
غاز الميثين موجود هناك بكثره او يعني
بكميات وفيره فيستطيع استخدامها لتكوين
الماده المحتاجينها للوقود فهذا يسهل
عمليه استخراج الوقود من المريخ على سبيل
المثال شكرا جزيلا من الكويت استاذ مساعد
بكليه دراسات التكنولوجيه سابقا دكتور
محمد قاسم شكرا دكتور